سننتقل الآن إلى تقرير حصري لشبكة CNN
يبدو أن المرتزقة الروس المتهمين بارتكاب جرائم حرب في أوكرانيا متورطون
في الصراع في السودان،
تقرير مراسلة التحقيقات الدولية الكبرى نعمة إلجار عن
جهود مجموعة فاغنر لمساعدة
القوات شبه العسكرية
[موسيقى]
سودانية و  احتفلت الجيوش الليبية
بعملية مشتركة ناجحة
يوم الأربعاء 19 أبريل بالقرب من
الحدود الصحراوية النائية بين ليبيا والسودان،
حيث استولت على حامية شيفروليه
التابعة
لقوات الدعم السريع شبه العسكرية المنافسة في سيدني،
قوات الدعم السريع، ولكن لماذا تعتبر هذه القاعدة العسكرية
مهمة جدًا نظرًا لبعدها عن
المعركة الوجودية في العاصمة السودانية
لأن شبكة سي إن إن يمكن أن تكشف أن القتال في
هرطوم يتأثر بما كان
يحدث في تلك الحامية، وهي
حملة إعادة إمداد روسية يدعمها
لاعب إقليمي رئيسي تهدف إلى تحويل
دفة الحرب في السودان لصالح قوات الدعم السريع
التي  كانت متلقية رئيسية
للتدريب والمساعدات العسكرية الروسية
بالتعاون مع كل الأنظار على فاغنر، وهي
مجموعة بحثية تركز على الوكيل الروسي فاغنر،
وحققت شبكة سي إن إن في
الوجود الحالي للمجموعة في ليبيا، كما يمكنك رؤيته
هنا في 16 نيسان/أبريل، بعد يوم واحد من
بدء القتال في الوهم الروسي  76
طائرة نقل في قاعدة الجفرة في
ليبيا تم تحديدها سابقًا من قبل
المخابرات الأمريكية على أنها قاعدة فاغنر وبعد ثلاثة أيام،
هذه الطائرة نفسها برعاية
متتبع الرحلات وخبير الطيران كرجان
العائد من القاعدة الجوية الروسية في
اللاذقية بسوريا قبل العودة إلى
الطيران الليبي.  بدأت صور قاعدة الهديم لتلك
الطائرة نفسها في الانتشار عبر الإنترنت في
17 أبريل/نيسان متجهة نحو
السودان، وتقول مصادر سودانية وإقليمية لشبكة "
سي إن إن" إن الأسلحة تم إسقاطها جوًا إلى
قوات الدعم السريع خلال هذا الإطار الزمني في الفترة من 15 أبريل إلى
18 أبريل/نيسان إلى حامية شيفروليه
خلال فترة من القتال العنيف.  القتال
يعزز قوات الدعم السريع، وتقع
قاعدتا الهديم والجفرة اللتين
انطلقت منهما سهول فاغنر في ليبيا
تحت سيطرة المشير
خليفة الذي يقود الأراضي في
شرق ليبيا، كما أن قائد
قوات الدعم السريع
لديهما تحالفات استراتيجية مشتركة.  أحدهما
مع فاغنر الذي يستضيف نصفه على
أراضيه في ليبيا والذي
كشف تحقيق سابق لشبكة CNN أنه
يعمل مع الحامدي لاستخراج
الذهب السني، والثاني مع الإمارات العربية المتحدة
التي استغلته لإرسال قوات
إلى الصراع في اليمن ودعمته
بعد ذلك في  القتال في ليبيا
ماذا يعني كل ذلك بالنسبة للبؤس
والصراع المستمر في السودان، فهو يعني
أن كلاً من الجنرال الليبي الإقليمي واللاعب
العالمي روسيا يضعان
إبهامهما على النطاق الذي يزيد من
المخاطر على
توازن القوى العالمي في المنطقة.  وبالنسبة لشعب
السودان العالق في مرمى النيران
CNN لندن
تواصلت CNN مع كل من
الجنرال الليبي ومجموعة فاغنر أن
تحقيقنا أه حتى الآن لم يرد رد
مراسلون بلا حدود في بيان لـ CNN نفت
تلقي مساعدات من روسيا أوليفيا